哈囉我是小分類這次我要給你們分享一個
不花一分錢就能夠讓生存變健存的方法
不是用什麼化妝品去遮蓋
也不是吃什麼東西
就是能夠讓我們改善我們本身的這個存色
這個是我現在的裸存
我是用的iPhone的原相機拍攝的
我也沒有擦扣紅
這是我以前的一個存色
是屋子色的
很鹹老也沒有細色
我現在也不是說存色很鹹
但就是正常的是紅潤的
沒有病臺了
現在擦上這種裸色的層面就會很好看
但我發現我的存色變起來了之後
我就去問跟我做的同樣事情的朋友
他也是說他的存色變得粉嫩了
那我是做什麼事情呢
就是女獎
我明显了兩個月之後我就發現我的氣色變好了
思綿的時候不會有病太感了
他的原理就是當我們在攤推
明显的時候有點像大座
是可以讓我們身體的氣賣跟唱通的
我們的存色發佈發自
一個是和我們人的氣血不同有關
還有一個是內心如果有長年了
已經下來的情緒壓抑
這樣悲傷憤怒這些負面情緒
這些壓抑的情緒也會導致我們身體肚色
氣色就不好看
像不入氣的母親一身氣胎的男水就會變少
就是因為一下子肚住了
我想能會讓我們的內心平靜下來
內心激壓的那些情緒肚色
也會慢慢的釋放出去
氣血慢慢的就會通常
氣色就會變好
不只是存色會變得紅潤
我們的臉色也會變好
如果簡單的稍微想要怎麼影響
就是我們盤推
你一個舒服的姿勢做好
臂上眼睛把我們的注意力放在我們的呼吸上
跑神又沒有關係
再把這注意力就拉回來
放回呼吸上就可以了
每天明显15到30分鐘
我你們感信句話可以去看一下
養定醫果實的這本書
裡面有大量的實用數據來證明明显得
豬豬好處
好
那我說完了
日本的方法之後
我做來分享一下治標的方法
就是用一些可以去死皮的護唇膏
有一些護唇膏不只可以資認嘴唇
還可以去死皮
我們嘴上的死皮少了之後
就會看起來軸嫩很多
而且你沒有那麼多唇紋
唇色有個看起來跟嫩一些
這兩隻都是我很喜歡的發現
可以去死皮的護唇膏
這隻護唇膏是我最近發現的
他很好用很資訊
而且他的資訊效果很持久
不是給種服裕表面的假潤
我晚上他當天早上嘴唇都是潤潤的
之後又是臉經稍微的錯一錯
能錯加一些死皮
最唇就會變得很柔嫩了
唇膏也會減少一些
他是這種極壓的幫狀
方便寫帶早萬都能擦
在擦一些比較薄乾的口紅
之前能用他做一個打底口紅
也會沒有那麼乾
然後就是這隻我之前分享過的
他也是很滋潤的
比他要稍微的黏一點
這隻晚上塗了之後
到第二天早上也能擦出些死皮
最唇也會變得很柔嫩
也能減少一些唇紋
但他是這種唇膏的樣子
不是我白天帶出門塗
因為塗的時候口紅
會把這個棒棒弄髒
這個做完間的唇不清款很合適
那以上就是唇色編證的方法
明想再加上用一些能夠去死皮的護唇膏
感謝給你們
那我們下次見
拜拜